you were twice deployed in the middle
east flying the fa-18f super hornet
can you briefly tell the story of your
career as a navy pilot sure
so i joined the navy in 2009 right after
college i went to officer
essentially officer boot camp officer
kinder school
i applied as a pilot and i got into the
pilot that was the advantage of going
that way is that i essentially choose
what i wanted and if i got in great if
not i didn't get stuck doing something
else so you knew you wanted to be a
pilot i did
i joined i went through my initial
training i went through primary flight
training that all aviators go through uh
and i did well enough that um
you know one of the first lessons i
teach in the navy is that
you know you can have a great career in
the navy and you can you know see the
world and do what you want but at the
end of the day it's all about the needs
of the navy and what they need so you
know they may not have the platform you
like or you know you may not necessarily
get to choose your own
own adventure here but i was lucky
enough that there was one jet slot in my
class and i was uh lucky enough
fortunate enough to get it so it was a
jet slot so but yeah what that means is
that i was assigned actually a tail hook
at that point which meant i would go
train to fly aircraft and land on
aircraft carriers
um and there's essentially three
aircraft that do that at the time is the
f-18
and the um
e2
and the c2
c2 is kind of like the male truck for
the boat
e2 is the one with the big radar dish on
top
and then there's all the f-18s so e2 is
comms is c2 mail truck yeah what's the
c2 baseball and mail they
and they're the ones that bring supplies
to the ship via air and people sorry if
i missed it is it a plane is it a
helicopter it's a plane okay
all right and the f-18 is a fighter jet
correct okay so i select a tail hook
which meant i could get one of those
other ones but 80 of them were so are
jets so i was in a good spot at that
point and that's when i went to meridian
mississippi to fly my first jet which
was the t-45 gauze hawk cool so what
kind of plane is that is that is that
that's what you were doing your training
on that's the jet aircraft you get in
before you actually go to the f-18
it is a carrier capable so go to the
boat for the first time in it during the
day
drop
fake bombs do dog fighting um
low levels formation flying day and
night
that's a pretty plain
yeah yeah and it looks like a cone so
that no one hits it
okay so it's usually not used for
fighting it's just for training it's
used for training how to fight got it so
what was that like was that the first
time you were sort of really getting
into it yeah that was really interesting
because before that it was a 600
horsepower prop plane and going from
that to the t45 is one of like the
biggest jumps in power and like
navy you know machine operation how much
horsepower does the 245 have
approximately
like 15 000 or so so it's a huge jump
from 600 you said horsepower about
so it's a big big leap but it's a jet
you know so it performs differently it's
faster and right and what that means not
just because it's faster your whole mind
needs to be faster everything happens
faster in the air now right those calms
happen faster um your landing gear has
to come up faster everything just
happens faster in a jet and so it's a
big jump
and i never forget going on my first
flight
in that aircraft
it was a formation flight for someone
else and i was just in the back watching
and there was instructor in the flight
and so what that means is
instructors in a single aircraft and
then there's three or four other
aircraft and they're learning how to do
joins and they're learning how to fly in
formation
and as a new student in the back it's
amazing right because you know photo op
time and all this like i'm seeing
aircraft up close for the first time
it's awesome
um
and on the way back um
we couldn't get our landing gear down uh
ironically uh so
it you know to make a long story short
because it's overall not that exciting
uh we couldn't get the gear down we
actually went to go do a control
ejection
uh to the target area that where that is
about 15 20 miles to the north of the
base
did you wait did you just say that's not
that exciting
well
because that to me is pretty exciting so
that i mean how
first of all i mean uh i mean that must
be terrifying like uh early on in your
careers haven't haven't seen those
things
um
that yeah like how often does that kind
of thing happen
decent more than you would think more
than you would think there was no
significant panic this is like
misunderstood this is what has to be
done in this case i think i was probably
just too dumb to realize the
significance of it because as a new
student you know not really appreciating
you know just what is ahead of me if we
are rejecting um
but at the time it was more it was just
like wrote right because i was back
there and then i went from a observer
mode to a
i'm going to provide you the help that i
can provide you as a member of this crew
you know mode and so it was less about
i'm you know on this 20-mile trip and
thinking about my um how vulnerable i am
you know we're going through checklists
we're talking to people we're getting
ready so
no it wasn't it wasn't fearful and the
whole time we were doing one of these to
try to get the uh
gear down so we're unloading the jet and
then loading it back to try to get the
gear out
with the stick and um
and it came down it came down halfway um
there just on its own so we came back
around and we did like a safety trap in
case there was a problem with the gear
and that was my first flight you know uh
a little bit of serendipity but i'm
going to fast forward a bit and i went
back to the squadron's instructor
about five or six years later and i was
an aviation safety officer at this point
which meant i was responsible for
investigating mishaps
and
a
a student went in and he he went in the
back seat of a forum flight
just like the one i went on uh and he
went out and he ended up ejecting on
that flight the exact same type of
flight uh they went out and they had a
runaway trim scenario and it caused the
aircraft essentially just inverted
itself almost 180 degrees
uh at about 600 feet over the ground and
they punched out just slightly outside
the ejection window at about 300 400
feet or so but they were completely fine
um
so you know and then about
two months later we had another ejection
about three months after that we had
another ejection so
um unfortunately you know it can it can
be more common than people think what
does it feel like to get ejected
thankfully i don't know i can private to
you i can tell you what it's like from
what i've heard but i truly think it's
one of those things that you just don't
understand until it happens
uh it's like instantaneous about 250 g's
which is only possible because of
inertia in our blood
right so you can actually get like 250
300 g's for like a few milliseconds and
then it backs off to like 40 or 50 g's
to get you away from the vehicle itself
and so
um you know you may lose consciousness
um if you
do you know who knows where you wake up
um you know you could be in a tree you
could still be falling uh you could be
in the water so the physics of that is
fascinating how do you eject safely
do you know the story about how that was
tested at all i don't know the full
story but uh there was no guessing
nobody knows the full story there's
probably a lot of shady stuff going on
but anyway you mean like in the early
early days or they suck a flight dock up
to a rocket sled and just see how much
their body could take it
and he turned a lot of his body into in
the mush in the in the process of
getting that science done but i saved a
lot of life
people
used to be tougher back in the day
that's how science used to be done
you